hello and welcome to today's
presentation a live broadcast of tales
from the clinic presented by the
american society of human genetics lab
roots and our clinical genetics team
here at the University of Washington
Medical Center we're excited to have
this educational virtual meeting for you
all today my name is Lauren I'll be your
moderator for today's event we hope to
make this event as interactive as
possible please use the green Q&A button
to the bottom left of your screen we've
provide prepared several slides in
several cases to go through with you in
hopes they will be relevant especially
to those practicing in primary care feel
free to submit questions that are
related to some of the cases that we've
prepared but also related to things that
you've seen in clinic that you think
would be relevant to a broad audience
we'd be happy to be fielding those
questions both during our presentation i
should say their presentation and
afterwards we have some time allotted
for questions and we'll try to get
through as many as possible but right
now I'd like to hand it over to our
three speakers today we have dr. fuqi
hazama dr. Eric Connick and miss Laura
Amendola one other housekeeping item is
that before we get to the end of the
presentation there's an opportunity for
free continuing education credits so
make sure you stick around and we can
walk you through what those steps are to
obtain those credits at the end but for
now I'd like to hand it over to our
speakers hello and welcome to the tales
from the clinic broadcast from the
University of Washington my name is dr.
Fuji hazama and I'm the clinic director
of the adult genetics clinic here by way
of introduction I just want to explain
for a minute in a minute for those of
you who aren't aware of the role of a
clinical geneticist dr. Connick will
describe the role of a lab geneticist
and Laura Amendola will discuss the role
of a genetic counselor after that we'll
launch right into the cases so a
clinical geneticist is a physician who
does graduate medical
education residency training in the
field of clinical genetics so I am board
certified in clinical genetics and have
over 20 years of experience in the field
so as a physician who specializes in
genetics I see patients in my clinic who
have themselves a genetic condition or
have a family history of a genetic
condition and I and my colleagues
diagnose evaluate and manage these
patients okay hi I'm dr. Eric Connick
and I'm a laboratory geneticist so I'm a
physician and I've gone through with a
postgraduate education in pathology and
laboratory medicine as well as molecular
genetic pathology and so our role in the
laboratory is to take the scientific
literature take the medical needs
develop new laboratory procedures and
make those available to patients and
physicians to help in the diagnostic
process hi I'm Laura Amendola I'm a
genetic counselor genetic counselors
have specialized master's degrees and we
work in a variety of settings in
research in the laboratory as well as in
the clinic our patient population is
similar to the medical geneticists so
patients and families who either have or
at risk to have a genetic condition and
we work with patients to talk about
genetic testing options help them make
informed decisions and then interpret
the clinical significance of genetic
test results and provide psychosocial
support throughout that process okay so
you may be aware that in genetics
clinics as some of them specialize in
prenatal conditions pediatric genetics
or adult genetics in our clinic here we
specialize in primarily seeing adult
patients and so we thought that we
present some recent cases from our
clinic for you and again you're welcome
to ask questions during the presentation
so the first case is coming for a family
history of breast cancer and the patient
is a 25 year old woman who went to see
her primary care provider for a wart on
her index finger and she said by the way
his concern also concerned about her
family history of cancer so her primary
care physician asked some questions and
then referred her to the University of
Washington adult genetics clinic for
consultation so what kind of a family
history might one elicit in this kind of
a situation so here is a sample pedigree
and here is the probe and indicated by
an arrow here is her mother and her
father and so here we have a situation
where each grandmother had breast cancer
but after menopause so diagnosed at age
65 and the maternal grandmother and at
age 73 in the pattern or grandmother we
also know that breast cancer is quite
common in the general population one in
eight women will develop breast cancer
so it's not unusual to have a family
history of one or even two female
relatives having breast cancer at an
older age in this situation also notice
that of course it's a grandmother on
each side of the family so they're not
genetically related to each other so
this is what I would consider to be a
non concerning family history that's
more typical of sporadic breast cancer
and not highly suggestive of a genetic
etiology whereas this particular
patients breast cancer family history of
breast cancer was more like this so this
is the same pick this is the patient
again the proband who presented for
consultation and her mother actually
died of breast cancer in her 30s I'm
sorry of varying cancer in her 30s a
maternal aunt died of breast cancer at
age 41 and then the maternal grandmother
great-grandmother and also these great
aunts all had breast cancer at young
ages so this is a very concerning family
history of breast cancer for the
following reasons first of all we see
breast cancer in several generations so
it looks as though something is being
transmitted through the family
additionally the breast cancer is
predominantly having a happening at
younger ages which is again a clue to
potential genetic cause for the breast
cancer in this family and finally
there's the combination of breast and
ovarian cancer
which raises concern for hereditary
cancer risk more than just a history of
breast cancer alone finally I will also
mention that this woman's mother because
of her striking family history of breast
cancer actually underwent preventive
mastectomy to try to prevent the breast
cancer based on her family history and
unfortunately subsequently developed
ovarian cancer which she did not know
was also associated that she was at
increased risk for so what does happen
after the patient is referred to our
clinic so before the visit we spend time
actually obtaining and reviewing records
on the patient if she herself has had
cancer and also medical relevance on
relevant that is affected family members
who've also had cancer we think that's
very important to establish the accuracy
of the diagnosis which may be reported
or misunderstood by the patient herself
at the actual visit we take a thorough
medical and family history and draw a
pedigree such as I've just shown you do
a targeted physical exam for physical
features that could be suggestive of
rare inherited causes of breast cancer
and we provide what we call pretest
genetic counseling about the risks
benefits possible outcomes of genetic
testing we cover whether this is the
testing is likely to be covered by
insurance the implications for the
individual's own medical care and also
the implications of genetic test results
for her family members so in this
particular case this patient because
this was a few years ago underwent
specific genetic testing of the brca1
and brca2 genes and she had sequencing
and deletion duplication analysis to
testing nowadays we might consider
actually sending instead of testing
limited to those two genes a panel of
high-risk breast cancer genes the
results of her testing showed a deletion
of portion exon 17 of the brca1 gene and
so the interpretation of this genetic
test result is that it's pathogenic
which means that it would greatly
increase her risk to develop breast
cancer
or ovarian cancer in the future and is
consistent and explains we think her
family history okay so if we so what do
we know currently about the risk of
resident ovarian cancer that's
associated with mutations and the BRCA
genes so again these are the strongest
genetic risk factors for the development
of hereditary breast and ovarian cancer
they've been very well studied over the
past 10 to 15 years and so a great deal
is known actually about the cancer risks
associated with these so we can see that
the breast cancer for a woman with a
brca1 mutation is increased from the
population risk of twelve percent to
around forty to eighty seven percent and
the risk of breast cancer with a brca2
gene mutation is twenty eight to eighty
four percent you can also see that
compared with the general population
risk for any woman to develop ovarian
cancer of less than two percent that
also dramatically increases to 27 to
sixty-three percent in the presence of a
BRCA gene mutation importantly men can
also inherit and pass on these genes and
there is an elevated risk of breast
cancer in men who carry BRCA gene
mutations breast cancer in men is
otherwise quite rare affecting fewer
than one in a thousand men so the
relative risk is substantial although
the absolute risk of between say one to
five percent is quite small for male
breast cancer and finally it's also
thought that mutations and the BRCA
genes increase risk of prostate cancer
in men we also know from longitudinal
studies over the past decade that
prevention is effective so in other
words we don't just do testing to tell
women that they're at elevated risk for
cancer the testing can be coupled with
effective cancer prevention methods so
in other words if women come to our
clinic they're identified to be at
elevated lifetime risk for cancer
through genetic testing before they
develop cancer they can be offered a
high risk screening such as breast MRI
more frequent mammograms chemoprevention
is an option for some women to reduce
the risk of breast cancer or they could
choose to undergo preventive surgery
such as prophylactic mastectomy or
removal of the ovaries and fallopian
tubes as a very effective way to prevent
developing those cancers in the future
and we know that the surgical methods
can reduce the risk of restaurant
ovarian cancer by ninety to ninety-five
percent okay so this is another family
that I saw in the clinic recently and so
these two sisters came to the genetics
clinic and they're 25 and 27 years old
and have not had cancer their mother
actually was seen in our clinic a few
years ago she's currently age 51 and she
at the time had several years ago had
normal testing of the brca1 and 2 genes
including sequencing as well as deletion
duplication testing and she also
underwent testing of some additional
genes here mlh1 msh2 and msh6 for the
separate family history that she had of
her father passing away from colon
cancer at the age of 50 so our patients
maternal grandmother is living in 78 she
had three primary cancers including
left-sided breast cancer in at 38
right-sided breast cancer at 42 and
ovarian cancer at 49 there's some
additional family history of a cousin on
the paternal side of the family who died
of breast cancer very young okay so I'd
like to put up a polling question next
and see what the audience thinks in
terms of what would you do with this
with this family in terms of what would
you offer for genetic testing okay so
these are the choices select the single
best answer a offer the 27 year old
sister genetic testing for brca1 and 2 B
offer both sisters testing with a large
panel of rest ovarian cancer
risk genes and hereditary colon cancer
genes see offer updated genetic testing
to their mother or D offer genetic
testing to the grandmother for breast
and ovarian cancer risk genes so we'll
give you about 15 seconds to answer the
question and then we'll see what the
audience thinks
ok
okay so the top answer here was offered
genetic testing to the grandmother for
breast ovarian cancer risk genes and
that is the single best answer the that
was followed by answer C which is offer
updated genetic testing to the mother
now I notice that these numbers are
awfully close however and so the third
best answer was offer both sisters
testing with a large panel of rest
ovarian cancer risk genes and few people
chose a answer a ok so I would say that
the best answer I would agree with the
audience is that the best answer is d to
test the grandmother the reason is
because she is the affected person in
the family and so she is the person
who's most likely to have a mutation by
testing the second best answer would be
to test the mother for updated genetic
testing since her testing was several
years ago I will also mention that the
mother has had colonoscopy and has not
had any polyps so some take-home points
from this case is that overall five to
ten percent of cancers are strongly
hereditary or genetic and clues to an
inherited breast ovarian cancer syndrome
include a diagnosis younger than 50
years multiple primary cancers in an
individual patient the combination of
breast and ovarian cancer in a family or
the combination of colon and uterine
cancer as well as cancers in two or more
generations on one side of the family
and of course we know that in the
Ashkenazi Jewish population there is a
about a 1 in 40 chance to be a carrier
of three common founder mutations in the
brca1 and 2 genes it's also important to
recognize that the patient who comes to
you may not be the most informative
person in the family to test and so
genetic testing and evaluation often
involves the family and also we do think
that adequate pre test as well as
post-test genetic counseling are
critical to the eval you
dr. hossam I have one question here from
one of our attendees relating to the
family that you just went over and maybe
you can go back to that pedigree the
question is for a lot of these folks the
27 year old is the patient that's
presenting in their clinic sometimes
have limited availability of their other
family members to get in and be the one
to get tested and so how reassured would
you be for that 27 year old patient if
you were to order that entire gene panel
and it was negative so that certainly
does reduce the risk for her of having
an inherited breast cancer condition
however the the problem is the
limitation of that testing is that a
normal negative result in someone who's
unaffected can never eliminate the risk
back to the population risk because we
do not have an explanation for what
caused the breast cancer in the family
yet without identifying a mutation in a
breast cancer predisposition gene in an
affected person and then another
question from an attendee is and I think
it's if you do testing and it was
negative like in that scenario or if we
choose not to do testing for the time
being what screening are you
recommending for those two sisters based
on the family history right so there
actually are some risk models that we
can use to calculate their lifetime risk
and so typically when the risk is above
twenty percent then we offer high risk
screening it's important to recognize
also that in addition to testing that we
work with other providers in for example
the high risk clinic and other
specialized clinics here so that we can
refer them for recommendations regarding
screening and prevention
okay so I'm going to move on to the
second case then which is an individual
who has a family history of sudden
cardiac death so this is a patient who's
a previously healthy sixteen-year-old
boy who was playing soccer with his
friends who collapsed on the field they
called 911 taken to the emergency
department unfortunately he could not be
resuscitated and died in the hospital so
this case went to autopsy and showed
hypertrophy of the left ventricle of the
heart as well as a symmetry of the
interventricular septum so in terms of
what causes sudden cardiac death and
healthy young people there was this
review several years ago in the New
England Journal of Medicine which
identified cardiomyopathies as a single
most common identifiable cause and of
those hypertrophic cardiomyopathy is the
most common there are also non
structural typically inherited
arrhythmia conditions that can cause
sudden sudden unexpected cardiac death
as well as some non cardiac conditions
such as drug abuse heat stroke and
asthma okay so hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy then is the single most
common genetic cause of sudden
unexpected death and healthy young
people and you may be aware of this
because when sometimes in the news if
you hear about an athlete for example
who collapses on the field this is
typically the cause that is found not
always of course and we know that
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy is
relatively common in the population
there's a prevalence of one in five
there's a prevalence of one in five
hundred people hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy we also known no is
genetically heterogeneous and is caused
by mutations in a number of different
genes encoding proteins of the sarcomere
and here you can see a normal heart on
the left and here you can see the
thickening of the wall and asymmetry of
the interventricular septum which are
typical findings in hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy on pathology
G or on imaging so in this case a so
called molecular genetic autopsy was
able to be obtained which means that at
the autopsy a tube of blood was saved in
an EDTA or purple top tube and blood
spots on filter paper were also saved so
this facilitated genetic testing
postmortem so then we met his parents in
the cardiac genetics clinic here and
genetic testing of 18 genes in a sample
from the autopsy showed a likely
pathogenic variant in a gene called my
BP c3 so this was a single base
substitution resulting in the
substitution in a misson substitution
and again the interpretation was likely
pathogenic so this brings up the point
that genetic testing is not always
positive or negative many labs use a 5
to your classification system similar to
this so pathogenic is disease-causing
likely pathogenic there is it's not as
strong as pathogenic but it's thought to
be ninety percent likely to be
disease-causing a variant of uncertain
significance is a sequence change or
other change in the gene that is
detectable but it's not known to
actually cause the disease likely benign
variation in a gene probably does not
cause disease even though other
mutations in that same gene do and
benign variants are not disease-causing
and found in the normal population ok so
this table is from a paper which is
published by Laura Amendola and
colleagues published in genome research
last year and the purpose of this table
is just to bring out the point that when
six different labs in the Caesar
consortium were asked given the same
variant and asked to classify it they
did not always agree so for example this
particular variant all six labs agreed
that it was pathogenic or disease
zing and but for other variants you can
see that there was a range of
interpretations across the six labs with
some four out of six labs here calling
this variant a variant of uncertain
significance and two of them calling it
likely pathogenic so this is actually
one of the active areas of discussion
and debate now in the genetics community
is classification of particularly new
variants and of course in the clinic
setting this is very important as to
whether we actually call something
that's found on clinical testing
disease-causing or whether it's
unrelated to the disease or it's not
clear okay in this particular family the
the probe Anne had three brothers and
sisters and so testing was offered to
the family as well as to the parents it
was determined that the likely
pathogenic variant found in him was
inherited from his mother she had a
normal echocardiogram so did not have
evidence for hypertrophic cardiomyopathy
however she has two nephews who were
also tested have the pathogenic likely
pathogenic variant and each of them had
abnormal echocardiograms consistent with
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy so in other
words further testing in the family gave
additional information about what we
call segregation supporting giving
additional evidence that this particular
variant was the cause of the
hypertrophic cardiomyopathy in this
family doctor sucess suck excuse me dr.
Hasan I have two questions here from two
of our attendees one being is DNA
routinely saved following autopsies and
if so who pays for that testing if we
want to use that saved DNA good question
so interestingly there's not a standard
procedure in terms of autopsies and I've
seen differences even from different
counties in the state of Washington so
it's not routine or mandated to save DNA
from autopsies I actually visited the
King County Medical Examiner's Office
here to talk to them about
the possibility of post-mortem genetic
testing and they told me that oftentimes
you know the results of toxicology takes
several weeks to come back and it's
really only at that time if the
toxicology is negative that genetic
etiology is considered and so we talked
about ways that maybe they could it
would be possible to save samples for
genetic testing if they were needed and
interestingly they felt from their
perspective it was easier to save tissue
then a tube of blood and then in terms
of the cost of genetic testing for
someone who has passed away that's also
an important question clinically and we
know that typically patients insurance
ends when they pass away so insurance
often does not pay for post-mortem
genetic testing and that can be an issue
when you're trying to find the cause of
death and someone who's passed away so
we do talk about options with the family
whether they have the ability or means
to self pay for that testing or there
can be other options such as charity
care and some organizations actually
provide limited funding for that type of
testing I can comment directly on the
autopsy so in academic medical centers
especially we routinely do save either
dried blood spots or we do occasionally
say blood as well as well as frozen
tissue and that's pretty common in
academic centers and then in terms of
hospital autopsies if there is a
compelling reason to do genetic testing
we do consider that on a case-by-case
basis for that particular autopsy and as
most people may or may not know the
autopsy is the one thing in most
hospitals that you can get for free of
course you have to pass away for that to
happen but so in in that particular
setting the cost of Jack testing would
be covered by the autopsy but we don't
do it routinely thank you
okay so our next case is related to
patient where direct-to-consumer genetic
testing came to play with her clinical
visit at the genetic medicine clinic so
this is another patient who has a family
history of breast cancer she is 47 years
old and her mother was diagnosed with
breast cancer in her 60s and passed away
at 72 she also had a sister who was
diagnosed with breast cancer in her 30s
and passed away at 42 her family history
as you can see the ancestry on her
maternal side is Finnish and Swedish and
paternal side is Irish and Norwegian and
that will be important later in the case
so this patient based on her family
history of breast cancer and the
increased risk for her had had a
mammogram which was normal and she also
did retain her uterus and ovaries at the
time that she visited the clinic so
based on the family history genetic
testing was sent for this patient and it
was a few years ago so again this was
brca1 and 2 genetic testing that
included sequencing and deletion
duplication of these genes and she was
actually found to have a pathogenic
variant in the brca2 gene so as dr.
Hasan mentioned pathogenic variants in
this gene increased the risk of breast
cancer up to eighty four percent by age
7 B as well as increase the risk of
ovarian cancer up to twenty seven
percent by age 70 and so for management
of this patient she was referred to a
prevention program for breast and
ovarian cancer at another local
institution and she did have a
preventive boofer ectomy soon after that
visit and was set up with a schedule of
screening for breast MRIs and mammograms
and was considering a prophylactic
mastectomy so about a year later the
genetic counselor who had met with this
patient received an email thanking the
genetic counselor for the work that she
had done with the patient and for
helping her through the process
and then she mentions that recently she
did the 23andme genetic testing after
her generous boss gifted this to her for
her birthday and she mentions that the
results of this 23andme testing came
back indicating that she has a lower
than average chance of breast cancer and
that she did not test positive for
pathogenic variants in either of the
brca2 genes she noted that 23andme does
mention that the test isn't exhaustive
for all BRCA variants but she felt that
this information disclosure could have
been easily overlooked or dismissed by
other individuals who hadn't had the
kind of exposure to exposure to genetics
that she had had and then she says that
if she had not done the genetic tests
with the genetic counselor she thinks
she may have received those results from
23 and me and felt reassured and not
move forward with clinical genetics
especially given the cost involved and
the cost difference so she asked the
counselor that when she has a moment if
she can explain why the myriad test or
the clinical genetic tests came back
positive and the 23andme was negative so
these are the results from this patients
23 in need testing and you can see in
the top box that the breast cancer risk
here is indicated to be below the
average risk and the ovarian cancer risk
for this patient is reported to be
typical and then the bottom box we can
see the three Ashkenazi Jewish founder
variants that were tested for in this
patient and these were all negative but
as you remember this patient does not
have astronauts a Jewish ancestry so we
would not expect those to be positive
and this isn't really an indicated test
for this patient and I think this case
brings up a few of the different
challenges that we see in the clinic
with direct-to-consumer genetic testing
one is potential misunderstanding on the
for the patient where we can see that
there is
is the potential for false reassurance
one results are returned that the
patient may not understand what actually
was tested for and then also the
potential burden for the clinical
providers in the genetics clinic to work
with patients who are looking for
interpretation of these results when
they may not have been fully informed
before the test was done or confused
when they receive the test results I do
not have any questions from our audience
for the direct-to-consumer portion of
the slides but I do want to encourage
the folks that are newer attendees to be
asking questions and using that Q&A box
in the bottom left-hand corner of your
screen we're happy to field questions
that are related to these cases that
we're presenting but also if you've had
experiences in your primary care
practice or other practice that you'd
like to run by some of our experts feel
free to do so I will also mention before
we move on and when we think about these
types of direct-to-consumer genetic
tests and what to do with the results we
actually do have a policy in our clinic
where we don't see patients being
referred for interpretation of their
direct-to-consumer genetic testing
because presumably that testing may not
have been done for a medical indication
and if the patient does have a medical
reason to come to the genetics clinic we
would like to see them for that concern
okay so I'd like to talk a little bit
about a case that I saw when I was a
medical student my primary care
rotations set of the patient was a 37
year old woman of Indian descent and she
came in for just a routine prenatal
checkup and the practice in the clinic I
was in was to offer carrier screening
for a multitude of different diseases
including cystic fibrosis and we allowed
the patient stopped in or out of those
particular carrier screenings and this
patient even though she had no family
history she was interested in pursuing
cystic fibrosis carrier testing so at
that time we took a sample of blood and
we sent to laboratory for a panel of 23
different mutate
shins for cystic fibrosis and the result
came back negative several weeks later
and the patient when she received the
results was very interested and she said
well great but how good is this test
detecting cftr or mutations in this gene
and people like me of people of my
descent and so we discussed it and yes
some of the answers we thought of are
listed here so it could be equivalent
and all different ethnicities it could
be an increased detection rate so the
testing could be more tuned to pick up
variants in this particular ethnicity it
could also be decreased in this
particular ethnicity or we may not just
have enough information and so looking
at the data what we see is that there
are different detection rates and
different ethnicities and so the astana
see jewish population has been very well
studied and so the particular 23
mutation panel that was used is most
sensitive in that population and so you
can see before the testing the carrier
risk is one in 24 and then with a
negative result the carrier risk goes to
1 and 380 if we look at the different
populations so non-hispanic whites it's
similar but then we go into hispanics or
african-americans or Asian Americans and
what we see is that detection rate drops
precipitously and so even though the
carry risk before testing is a little
bit lower than in the Caucasian
population it doesn't reduce the risk as
much with a negative result so our
patient asked a very appropriate
question so over the last several years
many different laboratories and
commercial companies have instituted
different panels for cystic fibrosis
screening testing and here are a couple
examples so we've gone to situations
where there are hundreds of individual
mutations that are tested and a variety
of specific sites and so a recent
publication looked at exome data in the
exome aggregation consortium or exact
and this is a database of 60,000
individuals from a variety of different
scientific studies not selected for
cystic fibrosis mutation status but that
information was captured and so what
this particular study did was look at
these different commercial panels and
say what is the carrier frequency we
detect in the 60,000 exomes that we have
and what you see is the paddles by and
large they do a little bit better than
the 23 mutation testing that's
recommended by this organizations but
they do a little bit differently if we
look to the far right of the graph if we
looked at the East Asians some of the
particular tests do much better and
others do about the same so in addition
to expanded panel testing there is
option to do entire gene sequencing of
the Cystic Fibrosis gene and so what we
see here is a study looking at that
particular test in different populations
and what we see is the detection rate is
much much better in all the different
ethnicities and similarly after the
testing we get a higher confidence that
a negative result truly means the fish
is a negative is negative for carrier
status thank you dr. chronic I have a
couple questions lots of people are
putting questions in now but a couple
related to cystic fibrosis testing one
of our attendees asks do you think the
current panel which I assume they're
referring to our 23 mutation panel
reflects the diversity of the American
population and then I would add to that
what do you think are some of the pros
or cons of automatically offering one of
those larger panels that you mentioned
that's a very good question and so I
think these data definitely speak to the
fact that the 23 mutation panel does not
represent the diversity we currently see
in the United States let alone worldwide
and so it does make sense to consider
these broader panels for certain
ethnicities the caveat is is that not
all the mutations that are going to be
detected have been well studied so as 23
mutations have been well vetted we know
that those are associated with cystic
fibrosis many of these other mutation
in these expanded panels or in whole
gene sequencing we may not have that
same information and so the risk is that
the results that are returned may be a
variant of uncertain significance and
that can put the position of the
practitioner in a difficult situation
talking with the patient about what
their risk actually is because we just
don't know and the data aren't there so
that's the downside of using expanded
testing thank you and i have lots more
questions coming back for you Laura
related to some of the
direct-to-consumer testing options let's
see one person asks as we're getting
results back from direct-to-consumer
testing I'm assuming in their practice
would those results be considered
confidential and HIPAA compliant with
those go in the medical records or do
those get shared with insurance
companies yeah so I think that is
something that may be less defined and
so it's a really good question it seems
like if it's information that the
patient brings to you in a care setting
it's something you talk about regarding
their medical care that that information
would go into the medical record and
then as we know information that's in
the medical record is accessible to
insurance companies but because it is
testing that's done without a provider
being involved in the ordering or that
initial interpretation you can see a
context where it doesn't become part of
the electronic record or the medical
history of that patient and potential
complications with that and then another
question that I think is probably
relevant for a lot of our folks that
work in primary care settings but they
ask to you specifically if you can
comment on where we are right now in
being able to in the context of carrying
out direct-to-consumer testing for
healthy patients that are walking in the
door to these primary care settings so
where are we right now what are the pros
and cons of what's out there and being
offered yeah I think one of the
challenges with what's being offered is
how it's being marketed in a way that it
seems
to consumers as a medical test where the
information that's provided is related
to ancestry or other non-medical traits
so I think that that's you know part of
the the information that we get that is
more may be validated like the ancestry
information and and what we get on the
medical side is is more challenging
there has been research on if we send
test two different companies are the
results the same for the same individual
and there is discordant in those results
and based on the different snips or the
different genotypes that are being
looked at by the different labs so I
think there's some challenging the
validity of that those results related
to medical conditions and then Leslie
I'll just mentioned there has been a lot
of research in the last few years
looking at outcomes from
direct-to-consumer testing where it
doesn't seem that there has been
significant harm being done to
individuals who are having the testing
so like in a psychological way but it's
really hard to quantify the benefits for
those individuals as well and we know
that that testing is being done by a
self-selected population of individuals
who are treatment seekers and who may be
trying to answer a medical question so
how that would play out as
direct-to-consumer testing increases
across the population will be
interesting to see so I think it's
important to realize if you have
direct-to-consumer testing that the
disclosure that comes with it is that
this is not for medical purposes it's
for information purposes so it's not a
substitute for a real genetic evaluation
in a real genetics clinic with a real
genetics provider we do see and we get
questions quite often from people about
their direct-to-consumer testing and
again our recommendation is not to treat
people based on those results
not to diagnose people based on those
results but to have an actual clinical
evaluation we typically see that
although it's marketed as being for
information purposes we do see patients
who come and they're trying to diagnose
themselves through direct-to-consumer
genetic testing and we think that that
is not a good idea and that harm can
come from direct-to-consumer testing
like the example that Laura gave where
the patient clearly said if she had not
had a visit to a genetics clinic and
clinical genetic testing she might have
thought that her own risk of breast
cancer was low I had another breast
cancer question come up dr. hazama that
maybe you can speak to this provider I
assume has a 50 year old patient who has
been up to date on her routine screening
everything has been coming back from
normal but her mother passed away from
triple negative breast cancer that was
first diagnosed when she was only 38
years old the patient did move forward
with brca1 and 2 testing which was
normal but the provider is wondering
what to do should they keep continuing
just with the routine screening as they
have been or should they recommend
additional testing to their patient
right so that's a good question and this
certainly does come up because of the
expanded panels of breast cancer testing
that are now available so in a situation
like that what we would recommend is
actually the patient come back to a
genetics clinic or consider updated
genetic evaluation if it's been several
years I can give you an example of a
woman that I saw whose mother had
ovarian cancer and the mother with
ovarian cancer who was the appropriate
person to test had negative brca1 and 2
genetic testing however as testing
improved over several years she went
back to the genetics provider and she
had additional testing and she was found
to have a mutation in another ovarian
cancer gene more recently discovered
called rad51 see so then my patient
who's the daughter who is cancer-free
was tested for that and she was positive
for that mutations so again test
limited to brca1 and 2 and this family
would have been uninformative thank you
I think we can move forward with the
next case and I'll keep taking questions
as they come and so our next case is
related to familial a ortak aneurysm so
this was a patient who came to clinic he
was 64 years old when he came and he had
a history of an abdominal aortic
aneurysm a few years before and you can
see from the pedigree that his mother
had also had an abdominal aortic
aneurysm as well as his maternal aunt so
it appeared that there was a pattern
potentially a dominant pattern in the
family and potentially an increased risk
for vascular complications or problems
in this individual so what is the
rationale for evaluating this individual
for a genetic risk for aneurysms the
first is trying to identify a diagnosis
to define the risks so thinking about is
there an increased risk for additional a
ortak or extra a ortak aneurysms two
sections or ruptures and then could
there be other non vascular issues for
this patient to consider secondly
thinking about management or prognosis
so for this patient genetic testing
could inform how extensive and how
frequently to do vascular surveillance
and if surgery is something the patient
is thinking of when to intervene could
this be an aneurysm that would progress
more quickly than another aneurysm that
does not have a genetic basis and then
what to expect with surgery could there
be a difference in the tissues of this
individual based on a genetic change and
then for some aneurysm conditions that
have a genetic basis specific
medications have been recommended and
are currently being evaluated and that
have been shown to be beneficial for
this population for example losartan or
a beta blocker and then finally looking
beyond the patient to family members if
a genetic causes identified for this
patient then family members who are at
risk to carry the same pathogenic
variant could be tested specifically for
that change and those that do have the
same pathogenic variant and thus have an
increased risk could be screened based
on that information and then those who
haven't inherited that variant could not
have screening because we know that they
would have the baseline risk for
aneurysms and that could you know save
them costly and potentially invasive
procedures in the future so this patient
had a genetic test for six vascular
aneurysm genes and they're listed here
and his results were normal so the
recommendations for this patient were to
follow up in clinic in one to two years
because we don't know all of the genes
that could be associated or are
associated with an increased risk for
vascular abnormalities so it's possible
we could identify a new gene in the next
few years also it's possible there could
be something in the genes that were
sequenced that was missed so potentially
a new type of technology that could be
developed may be applicable to test
those jeans again in the future we don't
recommend testing for other family
members in this family because a genetic
cause wasn't found and then finally that
this patient should continue with
screening based on the personal and
family history because it does still
appear that there's something going on
where there's an increased risk for this
person great now one question here from
one of our attendees speaking to that
and the question being for a family like
this where we're strongly suspecting a
genetic etiology should we pursue
additional testing like whole exome
sequencing and kind of where do you draw
the line where that becomes a benefit
yeah that's a great question and I don't
think that we have the data for
conditions like this at this time most
of the known genes that are associated
with an increased risk for vascular
problems
would be tested for on a panel so it's
not clear what if any increased yield
there would be by doing XOM sequencing
so I don't think that it's something at
this time that would make sense for a
family like this maybe in a few years
you know there could be potential
benefits about if an exome is done then
you could you know relook at the exome
in a few years so you don't have to have
an additional genetic test done however
cons could be insurance coverage for an
exome for this indication is probably
not going to be feasible so cost and
then also with exome sequencing there is
the potential for incidental findings so
that might be something that that is
something to talk about with the patient
and might be a consideration and another
question about this case but maybe for
dr. hazama why bother testing these
genes at all on this vascular panel what
if that doesn't change management how is
that going to help either that patient
or their family so there's two ways to
look at this so one is the diagnostic
implication so that you can say what the
cause is for this patient and for this
family oftentimes really the
cost-effectiveness or the utility of the
testing comes into play when we start
testing other family members because if
other family members are having frequent
expensive screening like echocardiograms
if they did not inherit the known
genetic risk factor in their family they
can stop screening so you can really
target interventions at people who need
it and the other and the other point
here is that conditions like Eric
aneurysm can be fatal so again what we
want to do is identify the people who
are at risk and Institute screening and
prevention for that individual for those
affected individuals or at-risk
individuals and then before we go on to
the next case we have someone one of our
attendees asking an unrelated question
which we welcome feel free to submit
them and this is do you have any
comments on what testing these providers
should be doing for someone with
habitual abortions or having stillborns
without dysmorphic chain
should they be testing on products of
conception kind of what are the
guidelines and what are your
recommendations along those lines so I
think it depends first of all on the you
know the history of the pregnancy
history have they had any successful
pregnancies at what at what stage in the
pregnancy have they had the pregnancy
losses so it sounds like there may be
some early losses as well as stillborns
in this case you know usually genetic
testing is not done after one or two
pregnancy losses but again for the if
there are three or more than typically
people do do genetic evaluation and it
can start with either just chromosome
analysis or microarray on the products
of conception and again this would
depend on the stage personally I've gone
down to the autopsy room and done
examinations of pregnancy losses or
still births to try to identify a
genetic condition you know in the
affected individual thank you and
another oh did you have something to add
oh it's going to add also an evaluation
of the parents to see if there's any
kind of like a translocation that one of
the parents carries or some kind of
Claudine condition and the mother I
think that those are you know baseline
tests that may have already been run but
something to consider great and then a
question that came through also kind of
an off the wall question but I think an
interesting one is do you have any tests
that your patients regret having or is
there one test in particular that they
come back saying that I wish that I
hadn't had that test and can you speak
to that I think that there are
conditions where we have a heightened
concern that there could be regret and
that those conditions often fall into
the category where there isn't anything
any change to medical management or
treatment for example with Huntington's
disease where it's a condition where
it's a neurodegenerative condition
there's nothing we can do about it it's
a hundred percent penetrant if you you
know have a certain number of repeats in
the gene and live to a certain age so we
do have a protocol with the genetics
clinic for
we meet with them for counseling they
visit with the neurologist and then we
have post-test counseling and return of
results in person to try and help people
think through the process and think
through what they would do with a
positive or a negative result to try and
mitigate that regret and I think that's
you know one of the goals of genetic
counseling is so people make informed
decisions but there's there's no way we
can no no the future and know if people
you know maybe they don't regret it
right when they got the result but maybe
ten years down the line they might feel
differently but all we can do is you
know share all the information we have
and support people through that process
great thank you so switching gears a
little bit so this particular patient is
a five year old Asian American child she
had her tonsils out for obstructive
sleep apnea and the physician prescribed
tylenol 3 which is acetaminophen and
codeine for pain management and so the
parents were very good and they
administer exactly a dose that was
recommended and they kept a very close
eye on her and what they noticed was
relatively quick after the dosing of
medication she started to breathe
shallow 8 she also seemed more lethargic
than they would have expected and then
when they looked at her eyes should they
noticed that she had pinpoint pupils and
she seemed more confused than they
expected and so being very concerned
they discontinued the medication watched
her very closely and luckily she
recovered so when they came to clinic
yet the parents were still concerned
about this particular interaction and
seemed to think that the drug had
something to do with it and they want
genetic testing they thought that this
had some genetic basis and so they come
to you and they ask what do you what
would you do and so would you reassure
the parents that the reactions
idiosyncratic there's nothing that they
can do they observed her closely and
that's good enough which would recommend
cytochrome p450 genetic testing whole
genome testing and analysis or
mitochondrial DNA mutation analysis just
give you a second to think about that
and in this particular case to answer
the question of the parents cytochrome
p450 testing is the best answer so if we
look at the metabolic pathway of codeine
codeine what we notice is that the SIP
2d6 enzyme is integral in the conversion
of the prodrug codeine to the active
drug morphine and also from hydrocodone
which is another batalla of codeine to
hydromorphone and so what we know about
the metabolism of coding to morphine is
that there are different phenotypes that
can be observed so there are ultra-rapid
metabolizers and these individuals show
an increased conversion of the prodrug
to the active drug we also know that
there are poor metabolizers people who
don't seem down an analgesic effect and
the reason is is because their body
can't convert the code eat into the
active morphine so looking a little bit
further these phenotypes you have the
underlying reason for this is that there
are some different characteristics so
the enzyme itself can have low activity
or no activity or have normal activity
or there can also be increases in gene
copies so depending on the combination
of the enzyme activity plus the number
of copies of a particular gene you can
classify people into different metabolic
categories so from poor metabolizers who
have low or absent activity and a normal
number of gene copies to people who have
a normal phenotype in terms of enzyme
activity increased numbers of genes and
so they show it's seen as a filter rapid
metabolism so the other thing to know
about the sep to d6 enzyme is that it's
involved in metabolism of roughly a
quarter of all drugs there are greater
than 75 variants that have been
identified and again in the situation of
codeine people who are poor metabolizers
have before analgesic response because
of reduced conversion of coding to
morphine and then ultra-rapid
metabolizers have the opposite effect
where they have too much of the morphine
on board and then they can have
increased response or the situation that
we saw in this particular child
again similar to the cystic fibrosis
case what we see here is depending on
the ethnicity we have different
metabolizer phenotypes and so what we
see is in people of Asian descent up to
twenty percent of the specific
population can actually be an
ultra-rapid metabolizer whereas within
the caucasian population roughly you
know one percent to five percent of
individuals would have that particular
phenotype so this particular individual
laboratory testing was sent off and the
result came back is a sip to d6 star 2 X
4 and what does this mean and so it
means that the star two allele has
normal enzyme activity but the X 4 means
that there's actually four copies of the
gene present and so the interpretation
of that is that for this particular
individual they fit with an ultra-rapid
metabolizer phenotype and so the
implications for this individual are for
codeine is not a drug that they would
recommend using on this particular
patient and actually the FDA has a black
box warning on this particular drug for
exactly this indication and the reason
for that is is that over the past 40
years or so approximately a dozen
children have died from this particular
reason and so definitely good to know at
the same time they don't recommend
routines sep to d6 testing for people
being considered for codeine dosing and
the other thing to know is that they're
approximately 25 other drugs on the
FDA's list where they indicate that the
metabolic activity of SIP 2d6 impacts
the effectiveness of a particular drug
but for all of those drugs they don't
recommend testing for this particular
enzyme so coming back to our patient you
we'd know that in this particular case
it had effect on that person but we also
have to consider implications for the
parents and the siblings which is
definitely important to the primary care
setting thank you and I have two
questions coming in for from our
attendees about this topic one about
cost did insurance cover the cost of
this pharmacogenomic test and another's
and you can answer that first i'll give
you the other
so in this particular case my
recollections the insurance was good
enough that it covered it but that's not
going to be the case in all situations
of the spectrum of different types of
testing this is on the relatively
affordable side of things so probably
several hundred dollars would be the
cost of testing but I couldn't
anticipate in situations where it would
not be covered thank you and then
another question asking in the presence
of a clinical reaction to the medication
how does it really help to classify the
myth the metabolism mechanism right and
in this particular case you know there
wasn't really any reason to go down that
diagnostic pathway it was more interest
of the parents and your persistence on
their part and so that's the reason why
you know and also just given the time
frame and things like that you know the
particular deaths that have been
associated with this particular reaction
there was a heightened interest but it
also gives information regarding of
potentially prescribing other drugs that
in the future right that are also
metabolized by the same enzyme and then
someone asks if this test is affordable
why do we recommend against this as a
routine test was how they freeze it so
it's not I wouldn't say it's necessarily
recommended against it's not endorsed as
a requirement for prescribing vast
majority of medications so the FDA has
very specific indications for a variety
of different drugs for metabolic enzyme
activity or other biomarkers around the
use of that particular drug and for a
variety of reasons they just haven't
come down and said for you know
delivering class of drugs X this is a
prerequisite before you dose the drug
thank you
okay and so the next case is also a
pharmacogenetic case this is a 12 year
old boy of Chinese ancestry who has
epilepsy and has been taking
carbamazepine for his complex partial
seizure disorder his epilepsy is well
controlled on the medication and he's on
the stable dose his mother comes to the
clinic and says that she's heard that
there's a genetic test to predict if he
will have a side effect from the
medication and she wanted to hear more
about that so it's important to
recognize that carbamazepine can have
very serious life-threatening even fatal
side-effects particularly from a toxic
epidermal necrolysis or stevens-johnson
syndrome or basically this there's this
horrible rash appears the skin can
slough and obviously it can be like a
burn the prevalence of this disorder is
about one to six nine and ten thousand
people of European ancestry and there
actually is an FDA alert about this
particular medication which came out in
2007 so basically this alert said that
stevens-johnson syndrome or toxic
epidermal necrolysis can be caused by
carbamazepine treatment and it's more
common in patients who have a particular
human leukocyte antigen allele called
hla-b 1502 and the fda went on to say
that this particular allele is more
common in people with ancestry across
broad regions of Asia Asia including
South Asian Indian ancestry and that
genetic testing for this allele is
clinically available and in this case
they actually recommended that people
with ancestry from these geographic
areas be screened for the allele prior
to starting treatment with carbamazepine
and that if they tested positive meaning
they have the 1502 allele that the risks
and benefits of treatment with
carbamazepine should be considered
before starting treatment so a little
bit more about the hla-b 1502 allele so
it's known to be present at
significant percentage of the population
in the Han Chinese in the Malaysian and
the Thai population however its present
in less than one percent of the Japanese
Korean and Sri Lankan population and in
approximately one to two percent of
Northern Europeans background so there
have been several papers which actually
tested the hypothesis that genetic
testing for the hla-b 1502 allele would
reduce the risk of side effects from
starting carbamazepine and this is a
study that came out in 2011 in which
they instituted widespread screening in
Taiwan prior to starting carbamazepine
and so they used historical data for a
baseline and indeed when people were
positive for the 1502 allele and were
advised not to take carbamazepine when
they presented to clinics then the risk
of stevens-johnson syndrome dramatically
decreased okay another paper came out a
few years later because that which
looked at carbamazepine induced
hypersensitivity in three European
populations and they found a different
allele which is hla-a 3101 okay and that
same year in two thousand and I think
it's 13 there was actually another paper
in human molecular genetics which found
the hlaa 3101 allele was the genetic
risk factor for carbamazepine
hypersensitivity in the japanese
population so I brought up this case
really to highlight some of the hazards
of ethnic based pharmacogenetics
screening in other words prescribing
based on someone's reported ancestry so
here's the problem so again the FDA
recommendation was that persons from
Geographic or region of Asia which they
define rather vaguely should have
genetic testing for the hla-b 1502
allele but again notice
that in the Japanese Koreans and Sri
Lankans that is actually a very rare
allele whereas the hlaa 3101 allele is
actually the most prevalent allele that
causes carbamazepine hypersensitivity in
Northern Europeans but also in a
significant proportion it's the most
common allele in the Japanese population
and is also present in the in the Han
Chinese population
so to go back to the FDA alert notice
that they also say toward the end of the
alert that patients who have been taking
carbamazepine for more than a few months
without developing skin reactions are at
low risk of these events ever developing
and this is true for patients of any
ethnicity or genotype including patients
who are positive for hla-b 1502 and
remember this patient had actually been
taking carbamazepine had a good
therapeutic response in terms of
epilepsy control from it and had been on
the medication for two years so
therefore in this particular situation
even though he's of Chinese ancestry
there's not an indication for genetic
testing to predict his risk to develop a
side effect from being on it because
he's already basically had the test and
has passed it of a general question here
related to pharmacogenetics in general
as this type of testing becomes more
routine who should these providers be
going to to console with as they're
trying to understand the implications of
these results right so interestingly the
this particular set of genetic questions
does not come to the genetics clinic so
often so I think that in terms of
implementation it tends to be
implemented more by the prescribing
providers so in other words you as a
neurologist prescribe anti epileptic
medication so then you become familiar
with a small set of genetic tests that
are relevant to for example prescribing
prescribing epilepsy medications
similarly oncologists are becoming
familiar with genetic testing that
guides precision treatment of cancers
and so on we'd be happy to see these
patients in the genetics clinic but
again this seems to be more a
point-of-care kind of genetic test
that's more specific around prescribing
good I would also mention pharmacists as
a potential resource to connect with and
then also the laboratory that did the
testing they might have some some
support
and some information about interpreting
interpreting the significance of the
results I know in some situations
there's been discussion about using the
electronic medical record for really
high-risk types of situations so for
example carbamazepine and so that's
something in terms of organizational
level using the the knowledge expertise
of the pharmacists of your geneticists
of your laboratory to discuss you know
what are the things that are really high
impact that we do not want to miss on
any any basis at all and so I know there
have been pilot trials and different
hospitals including here for alerts and
things like that so that's an option as
well I also i just want to mention
briefly a very good resource for
pharmacogenetics which is a website so
if you search for farm PHA RM gkb and
that has a lot of very useful
information on specific pharmacogenetics
that you can search either by drug or by
the genotype and I have an additional
question that just came in for the
Chinese boys non sensitivity to this
medication does that argue against
testing other family members for the
hla-b 1502 would have otherwise been
recommended to have testing I probably
would not go by that so liliana probably
would offer them testing so just a
comment on the genetic testing so
typically put these types of very
specific indications so hla b27 in
closing spondylitis or again this
situation where you're looking at a very
specific genotype the way the laboratory
typically does this is the only look at
that nucleotide change they don't look
at all the other nucleotides or the rest
of the haplotype and so with hla
especially we have situations where this
may be the genetic change in that
individual but there may be a mutation
that makes it so it isn't expressed so
called null allele and so you can't get
that information from the vast majority
of this type of testing so again kind of
speaking to the fact that this
individual may have inherited something
that makes them not susceptible but
their sibling or parent could have an
active form that would make them
susceptible thank you
oh and I was going to add that the
website that dr. hazama just mentioned
will be available in the toolkit so that
you'll be able to access that as well so
the next case is a healthy 50 year old
woman who recently moved to the area and
established care with a new primary care
provider and her family history was
taken and she's concerned about her
family history of Alzheimer's disease
and asked whether those genetic testing
predict to predict whether she will
develop it in the future she's currently
working full-time as an attorney and has
no concerns about her memory so when
someone comes to ask about Alzheimer's
disease then of course I asked why
they're concerned about it are they
themselves concerned that they have
early symptoms of it or not so again
this is a non concerning family history
of this war her family history her
mother had Alzheimer's disease diagnosed
at age 75 and she passed away from the
disease at age 80 and there's no one
else in the family with a history of
Alzheimer's disease so this family
history is more typical of sporadic
Alzheimer disease and not suggestive of
an inherent a strongly inherited form of
Alzheimer disease so this would be so
called sporadic Alzheimer disease such
as President Reagan had and this is of
course a very common age-related
neurodegenerative disorder that affects
memory and cognition it's very very
common in the population ten percent of
people over the age of 65 have dementia
with the most common cause being
Alzheimer's disease and up to fifty
percent of people over the age of 85
have dementia again the most common
causes Alzheimer's disease and the
second most common causes vascular
dementia we know that Alzheimer's
disease currently affects over five
million people in the United States and
this is predict predicted to increase by
about fifty percent by the year twenty
twenty-five and again for sporadic
Alzheimer disease this is known to be a
complex trait meaning that there are
multiple genes involved as well as
environmental components
so the strongest genetic risk factor
that's known for a sporadic Alzheimer
disease or late onset alzheimer disease
is genetic variation in a gene called
April lipoprotein II so we all have this
gene and there are three alternative
varieties of it or alleles called a to e
three or a four so an individual's
genotype can be one of the following
combinations because again each each
individual inherits one copy of April
Ephraim his or her mother and a second
copy from his or her father so we know
that the most common allele in the
population is III and we know that the
e4 allele increases the risk of
Alzheimer disease and lowers the age of
onset for sporadic Alzheimer disease
whereas the e2 apoe allele is protective
against Alzheimer's disease so in other
words the individual at lowest risk
would have e to e 2 and the individual
genetically at highest risk would have
be 44 okay so what about predictive
genetic testing for sporadic Alzheimer
disease which is the situation that the
attorney in the scenario came to the
clinic with so predictive genetic
testing in general is genetic testing in
a healthy person that is to predict
their risk of having a specific disease
in the future and of course we do this
routinely in the genetics clinic for
preventable diseases such as colon
cancer or breast cancer however
Alzheimer disease is different because
there currently is no preventive
treatment for Alzheimer disease and we
also know that April a genotyping is not
that good at prediction for Alzheimer
disease and so it's a current practice
guideline of the American Academy of
Neurology that April a genotyping is not
recommended to predict risk of Alzheimer
disease and a healthy person also
remember that apoe4 is a risk factor for
Alzheimer's
so apoe4 by itself does not determine
whether a person will develop
Alzheimer's disease so I look at a risk
factor as being similar to say for
example wearing a seatbelt or smoking
not wearing a seatbelt is a risk factor
for injury and a motor vehicle accident
smoking is a risk factor for lung cancer
and many other diseases but of course
smoking is not a guarantee that you'll
develop lung cancer because many people
who smoke do not however unlike
environmental modifiable risk factors
genotype cannot be changed and
individuals who are even at the highest
genetic risk who have the e4e for
genotype still may never develop
Alzheimer disease which again limits its
usefulness in predictive genetic testing
in contrast about 5% of Alzheimer
disease is what we would call early
onset familial Alzheimer's disease and
this is inherited as a Mendelian
autosomal dominant trait usually with
onset before the age of 65 and for early
onset familial Alzheimer's disease it is
strongly genetic with the penetrance
approaching a hundred percent and so a
person who is affected has a 50-percent
risk to pass it on to each of his or her
children someone who did not inherit
that disease allele is not at risk it
stops there and he or she cannot have
passed it on to children so what about
the situation for testing and prediction
for early onset familial Alzheimer's
disease in contrast to the late onset
sporadic Alzheimer disease so if you saw
the movie still Alice then this
situation is actually portrayed in the
movie and in the neurologists office
then she the paper she's advised
actually to go to a genetics clinic for
pretest counseling and so the
distinction here is that in contrast to
a PO a genetic testing which is a risk
factor a positive genetic test in for
example presenilin one is predictive
that that person who has that pathogen
variant will develop Alzheimer disease
so again to make a distinction
diagnostic testing is to help diagnose
someone who has Alzheimer's disease as
to what the cause in them is and to
provide information for family
predictive testing is doing genetic
testing in someone who is healthy and
unaffected to say can they will they
develop Alzheimer disease at some point
in the future and so of course that
particular scenario is very highly
emotionally charged and so we recommend
that this type of specialized genetic
testing not be done in a primary care
setting but be referred to a specialty
on neuro genetics clinic typically in an
academic center and that this type of
testing really does require careful
pretest counseling some patients at that
point as was brought up a little bit
earlier would decline to go forward with
testing at that time until they're
emotionally financially ready have
prepared their family and all that sort
of thing as well as post-test genetic
counseling and support for the results
we have two questions dr. hasami that
have come through so far the first
relates to medical management for a
patient that does test positive for one
of these predictive Alzheimer's genes is
there anything you'd recommend that they
change and if not how likely is it that
insurance is going to come forward to
pay for a test like that so the first
question was what kind of medical
management so one of the difficulties of
predictive testing is that we can say if
someone tests positive for a personal
and one pathogenic variant that they
will develop Alzheimer disease we cannot
say when they will develop Alzheimer
disease of course and so of course it's
part of their pretest counseling to make
sure that they understand that we know
that in families who are at risk for
either early onset familial Alzheimer's
disease or Huntington's disease which is
a similar scenario in terms of genetic
counseling that there's a wide range of
age of onset even within a family so
what we recommend that people do
obviously is really put some thought
into how they will you know
with the results obviously we want to
make sure that people have support in
terms of continuing with their career
their life making sure they're they've
made appropriate financial arrangements
considered power of attorney those types
of issues but basically again there's
nothing that we can do to prevent the
onset of alzheimer disease but for
sporadic on alzheimer disease there
certainly are risk factors for example
we want people to control their blood
pressure treat diabetes we know that
exercise is very good for prevention of
dementia continuing to be you know both
physically and mentally active that type
of thing and so then that second part
fell into if we can't argue to
insurances that medical management will
significantly change what's the
likelihood of that testing being covered
I think for a lot of insurance if it is
a familial condition where there's a
known pathogenic variant in the family
then that is something that is Moe is
commonly covered by insurance but I
think that is correct that that's you
know the number one evidence that
insurance wants to justify genetic
testing is is medical management I think
one of the things that we say is to
argue with insurance is if we know you
know a diagnosis it could potentially
decrease any evaluations done trying to
identify the cause of symptoms a person
could be having that would probably be
more challenging in an individual who is
definitely who is clearly not
symptomatic but that's one of the one of
the things that we have you know that we
use clearly for us you know the value of
a diagnosis and information for family
members is one of the things we take
into consideration but that doesn't
commonly come in to play for insurance
companies and then another listener
asked what's the effectiveness of
treatment for someone with the e4e for
genotype so some of those
recommendations that you mentioned to
reduce those risks how effective would
that be in that poppy
yes so of course like healthy lifestyle
and things and so and so on do not hurt
right so you're always talking about
risk benefit ratio I'm not sure that
we've actually proven quantitatively how
much it reduces the risk although I just
saw an article like last week that
people who actually have the e4 genotype
and eat fish at least once a week have
like less risk of going from mild
cognitive impairment to actual dementia
so Mediterranean diet is good for you
thank you and before we launch into the
next cake stories mentioned that we have
just eight minutes left okay and so will
try to go through as many questions as
we can and we'll get through one more
case okay so this is the last case and
this is a 52 year old man who came to
the genetics clinic because his mother
was diagnosed with hemochromatosis and
when I asked him he was actually
uncertain how his mother was diagnosed
but she he reports that she was being
treated for cancer at the time so
presumably she had some blood work that
indicated she could potentially have
this condition and was tested and
confirmed in her so the patient had a
serum ferritin which was greater than
500 nanograms per milliliter so very
elevated because the normal range is
between 18 to 270 he had additional iron
studies which showed he had an elevated
transferrin saturation elevated serum
iron and then he had genetic testing of
the hfe gene which causes
hemochromatosis and he was homozygous so
he had two copies of a common disease
causing allele called C 282 why so
hemochromatosis is a very very common
genetic disorder in the population it's
inherited as an autosomal recessive
disorder clinically some of those
features are nonspecific and include
joint pain bronzing of the skin diabetes
cardiomyopathy and in later stages
congestive heart failure and liver
cirrhosis it's caused by mutations in
the HFEA gene which actually result in
more
efficient or increased iron absorption
from the small intestine and one in 250
people of Northern European ancestry has
two mutations and is at risk to develop
hemochromatosis and more than ten
percent of the population population of
urine European ancestry is a carrier for
hemochromatosis so this particular
family pedigree was interesting because
we have here an affected mother and an
affected son so this would appear to be
dominant inheritance but it's what we
call pseudo dominant because it's
actually an autosomal recessive disorder
that's manifesting in two generations in
the family so in other words his mother
is affected because each of her parents
were carriers she had to pass on one
mutant allele to her son my patient and
he received the other allele from his
father who's a carrier but not known to
be affected by hemochromatosis so a key
question in hemochromatosis is what
percentage of individuals who are born
at genetic risk actually develop the
clinical manifestations of iron overload
the mainstay of treatment of this
condition is called therapeutic
phlebotomy which is basically donating
blood to reduce iron stores in addition
there are some other medical
recommendations such as avoiding taking
extra iron in diet like in the form of
supplementation from iron containing
multivitamins and avoiding excessive
vitamin C or alcohol which also increase
iron absorption so the basic concept
here is that at birth there's a cohort
of individuals who are born with a
genetic predisposition to have
hemochromatosis but how many what
percentage of those individuals go on
during their lifetime to develop the
biochemical signs of hemochromatosis the
elevated iron transferrin saturation and
so on and how many of those individuals
go on to develop clinical symptoms of
iron overload with iron deposits in
their liver pancreas heart and so on and
that typically doesn't have
until their 50s or 60s at that stage of
life so there actually was a study that
was published here from the University
of Washington which evaluated the
penetrance of hemochromatosis in a large
HMO and this is the study is called the
emerge network so they basically were
able to mine the electronic medical
record and they combine that with whole
exome data and so they had the cohort of
patients who are known to be homozygous
for the mutation and then they checked
the medical record to see how many
individuals had clinical evidence in
terms of their icd-9 codes for
hemochromatosis and so you can see here
that fewer than one-quarter of the men
who were genetically at risk developed
clinical hemochromatosis and for a
different genotype this compound
heterozygous genotype ninety-seven
percent of people did not have
hemochromatosis and only a very small
percentage had clinical hemochromatosis
the numbers are smaller for women women
are less at risk to develop clinical
hemochromatosis probably be it's been
theorized because they lose i earn every
month through menstruation so that is
the last case great and I just want to
thank everybody for their attention and
will be available in the network lounge
right after this for further questions
so and couple more housekeeping items
yes there is the opportunity to get
continuing education credits and so
there will be a siiii button located it
sounds like in the lower left-hand
corner of your screen and so you can
follow the prompts to obtain those
credits as well I wanted to let everyone
know that I'm told that this
presentation will be available on demand
for viewing that you can let your
colleagues know that this is out there
and you'll be getting an email from lab
roots letting you know of its
availability and then lastly like dr.
hossam Isaid we will be hanging out in
what is called the networking lounge if
you go to the meeting lobby of your
screen and enter the networking lounge
there's a live chat feature and the four
of us and our three presenters will be
to answer more questions unfortunately
the questions that we have that we
haven't had time to get through do not
automatically get transferred to that
section but if you feel free to type in
some additional questions and we'll try
to field them in that setting as well
but thank you for joining us and thank
you to our presenters today